Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
for those of you who have not seen this
video this is some [ __ ]
this video is about a bus monitor who is
verbally abused by a bunch of kids on
the bus to the point where she cries oh
hey anybody look in their eye area turns
I've seen some messed-up [ __ ] in my life
but this right here is some [ __ ] well
you know what let's just cut the
[ __ ] and get back to it
you already know what it is LGI so let's
get makeup bad oh you call it back how
dare you speak to this sweet old lady
that way you dirty mother you little
piece of [ __ ] fat looks fat hey now say
the f-word I'm gonna tell you something
right now
if I was on that bus and you call me fat
I would've beat the welfare and you get
up ask you illiterate mother see you out
there kid that's why you daddy left you
that's right I said and look at the
curse words coming out the mouth of
these little children what the hell is
going on in today's society I don't
never went out with the kid and I said
the worst shut up everybody on the bus
be like oh baby so shut up and look at
these little piece of [ __ ] people got
get arrested ain't nobody say nothing
ask you some kids how you go jaqen
already what you feel good about
yourself and you know what i'ma stop you
right there cuz I don't know what you're
thinking dude stop being so judgmental
they're just kids hey hey shut up
they're just kids that is the common
excuse and answer that
from everybody but I'm gonna let you
know something else y'all need to do
some extreme parenting on the ass man
put them in a jail cell full of 14
pedophiles and see how long their ghetto
attitude lasts you're fat
oh I'm fat huh well you want see
something else as fat huh you know what
I wouldn't even know what to do in a
situation because she can't smack the
kids because she's a bust mind that's
the problem you be made fun of my
children because if you smack a kid and
you forever be known to do that snack
kit if you don't spend kids and your
forever know to do they got punked by
kids so what would I do it I probably
spent them you know what I would even
hit you I would punish you in the most
ridiculous way possible all the time
your dick to the back of a Spanish bull
walk in front of it and be like Olay I
would take all you kids lock you up in
the Porta Potty and shake it up like a
pinball machine if you're white I'm
gonna let your ass in the middle of
concrete with the shirt the same plot
power if you are brother I would have
left you in the middle of a KKK meeting
with a shirt that said Berg grandpa's if
you were Asian I would probably call you
pants and that would pop and do it huh
this is a sad day world and I understand
that in the history of man that there
have been a lot of worse things done but
this is some disgusting [ __ ] it's so sad
because I feel that a lot of kids don't
really respect their elders anymore even
the worst of thugs have a chain of
command and respect their elders to a
certain extent I understand that their
children but kids when you do [ __ ] like
this do you have any idea how poorly you
reflect on yourself as a human being and
also to your parents you know what the
real sad thing about this is it was a
one kid that was doing it it was a group
of kids and even was worse than that
there was a whole bunch of other kids on
this bus that stood and didn't say
anything I want you to listen carefully
to this you never have to resort to
violence to stop someone from doing
something wrong but you got to take
action you could ask them to stop you
could have told the bus driver and I
pray that this incident happened some of
you kids went and told the right people
about the incident I'm going to say my
last piece kids and adults let this be
an example for the type of behavior that
should never be tolerated I said this
before but I say it again world
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] together
streebek dang yeah you always cool eh by
yourself what you do affect everybody
that you've touched that's something